2023 Wellness influencers really are the
gifts that just keep on giving hey
everyone I'm Abby sharp welcome to aby's
[Music]
Kitchen today we're going to be taking a
look at the Highlight Reel of the most
unhinged problematic Wellness influencer
advice and let me tell you this year did
not disappoint and by not I mean it has
been a dumpster fire of disappointment
before we dive in I want to give a shout
out to today's sponsor my Heritage so my
mom and I have always been really
interested in our family's history so
before my grandfather died he recorded a
bunch of tapes documenting his whole
life and they are so fascinating to say
the least so I've always been eager to
learn more about who and where I came
from and my Heritage makes it so easy to
build your family tree this is the
leading global service for family
history research and DNA testing they
have 90 million users and 19 billion
easily searchable historical records
plus Advanced AI technology for
repairing and enhancing historical
photos it's honestly crazy I've been
slowly working on the street bit by bit
and my plan is to share my findings with
my parents for the holidays along with
their own accounts so they can learn
more about their own ancestors but it's
really an amazing service so you
basically plug in as many family members
as you can can and then you can research
each one for old records related to
marriage licenses death certificates
newspaper clippings Maps schools and
more one thing I learned is that
basically every man on my mother's side
is named Alan uh which I guess is a
tradition that my sister and I kind of
put to bed but even if you don't have a
ton of information they make it super
easy to build your tree with their
instant discoveries function and they
can take old photos and basically bring
them to life it's super crazy but if you
want to start to build your family tree
and research your family history you can
check out my link in the description to
get a free 14-day trial of the my
Heritage complete plan to get started
today well let's start with this
misinformed video from Autumn baits
claiming that the protein and peanut
butter doesn't count 2 tablespoons of
peanut butter has 7 g of protein one egg
has 6 g of protein but the protein you
get from peanut butter doesn't really
count it has a digestibility score of 46
eggs have a score of 1.1 three this
measures how much protein you're
actually absorbing so when you eat one
egg you get that full 6 g of protein but
when you eat two tablespoons of peanut
butter you're really only maybe getting
3 G all righty now nutritionist Autumn
and I may not share the same approach to
nutrition but I think most of her
content is generally scientifically
sound but I feel like she really
misunderstood the assignment here so
Autumn's talking about the D score which
is the best method that we have to
assess ESS protein quality a score of 46
means that if you were to eat the
average requirement of protein from only
peanut butter only about 46% would be
usable by the body this is based on the
fact that plant-based foods are missing
or low in one or more amino acids all of
which you need to synthesize protein
tissue so peanut butter is limited by
methionine so if you were to only
consume peanut butter then of the 7 G
per serving only around 3 G would be UTI
I for tissue synthesis but who the is
only eating peanut butter for their
daily protein oh
Ethan if we were to Simply pair the
peanut butter with like a slice of bread
which has plenty of methionine you've
got all the essential amino acids to
utilize the protein in that peanut
butter Bread's limiting amino acid is
lysine but peanut butter has plenty of
that so it's like having two pieces of
paper with a few holes in each when you
layer in a variety of plant-based Foods
you fill in all the holes and you get
more available protein and by the way
you don't need to consume these
complimentary proteins at the exact same
time either that protein combining
theory has long being debunked so this
is actually a complete nonissue for
folks eating a normal non-restrictive
diet so if you like peanut butter enjoy
it as one of many sources of protein in
your day just because it's not the best
source doesn't mean that it doesn't
count next let's take a look at this
advice from frugivore page Shay this is
the number one rule of food combining
don't eat protein and fat with fruit
it's best to eat fruit by itself or
alongside vegetables and leafy greens
fruit digests very easily and quickly so
if you eat fruit along with a high
protein high fat meal all of the fat and
protein is going to get in fruit's way
and it's going to cause gas and
discomfort oh gosh honestly of all the
The Fringe diets out there I have to say
that the whole high carb fravor food
combining diet is probably the one that
makes the least amount of scientific
sense you just don't get it do you so
the suggestion that combining fruit with
anything that has protein or fat will
create some kind of like traffic jam in
your gut is so far from what the science
tells us for one our body is pretty
sophisticated it's not like a one lane
Highway we can digest different foods at
different rates because our body
releases the right cocktail of digestive
enzymes based on what we put into our
gut second digesting food really fast
isn't really a good thing like we don't
want fruit to just go right through us
as it would if you were to eat an entire
watermelon or banana smoothie in one go
because if it does our blood sugar would
spike crash and we will be hungry really
soon after despite eating an entire
watermelon protein fiber and fat AKA my
Hunger crushing compounds will help to
slow down the blood sugar response which
is one of the only food combination
strategies we want to follow I mean this
is the same Creator who insists on
keeping fat intake under 10% of calories
and that she got toned when she
eliminated all major protein sources so
yeah I think it's safe to take a hard
pass on this advice all right moving on
to some of the worst Wellness influencer
offenders online Bobby Parish of Flav
City I know there's a nationwide
shortage of formula still but have you
seen the ingredients in most they're not
the best the good news is there are some
better ones but take for example
something like this the first ingredient
is non-fat milk that milk is not organic
that milk is not non GMO meaning the
milk is GMO it comes from cows that eat
GMO grain I would never eat GMOs I
wouldn't want infants doing that either
strike number one how about something
like this see the sweetener in here it's
corn syrup salads why would they put
corn syrup in an infant formula cuz
they're trying to mimic the sweetness of
breast milk mother's milk well that
sweetness is lactose this is the
opposite of that GMO corn syrup which is
addictive and lights up your brain in
the way of a drug to give this to an
infant pretty pretty bad but Bobby I buy
organic formula well that's good cuz
like it says it's organic so it's non
GMO milk but look at the oils used in
here organic palm oil soybean oil
sunflower safflower oil they're trying
to mimic the fat content of mother's
milk but these even though they're
organic are highly processed highly
inflammatory High refined and those kind
of oils are also bad for the gut a baby
has the most gut microbiome they're ever
going to have at that age to start
destroying it with those ingredients is
bad news but what's the good news there
are way better ones that are not perfect
but way better try getting something
called Serenity kids made with 100%
grass-fed milk how about organic lauca
or organic hip from Europe those are way
better than these options just keep in
mind what you're putting in your infant
at this age is very important this is
quite possibly one of the most
problematic insensitive and toned deaf
Bobby videos he is at put up oh brother
this guy stinks and based on his content
repertoire that's saying a lot so first
of all is Bobby a pediatrician a
pediatric dietician even a person who
has attempted to feed another human
after pushing them out of his body
because as far as I'm concerned anyone
can stand in a grocery store and yell
about ingredients to a
camera but it gives them zero Authority
to speak on a critical topic like infant
nutrition at the time this video was
posted we were in the midst of a serious
infant formula shortage so honestly read
the room Bobby let's go through some of
his ill-informed grievances shall we
first of all GMOs not a concern for me
GMOs have undergone more detailed
evaluation than any other group of food
products that we consume and the data
overwhelmingly indicates that the
consumption of GMOs pose zero risk to
human health as for corn syrup solids
buddy Bobby next time just like do a
basic Google search before you get on
the horn but basically Bobby makes a
stink about the corn syrup solids being
high fructus corn syrup and that high
fructus corn syrup is addictive or toxic
or whatever lots to say here keeping it
succinct first of all the claims that
high fructus corn syrup is addictive is
based on rat data not humans but this is
a moot point more importantly corn syrup
solids aren't High fructus corn syrup at
all high fructus corn syrup has 55%
fructose to glucose ratio whereas core
and syrup solids are straight of glucose
Bobby also says something to the fact
that lactose is the opposite of glucose
which again points to how little about
nutrition he actually knows lactose is a
disaccharide made up of glucose and
galactose but because it was meant for
pries who often lack sufficient lactase
enzymes levels they mix it with glucose
to make it easier for them to digest not
all formulas have corn syrup solids but
this has a very specific clinical
purpose to help babies Thrive Bobby then
rounds out his video with his usual
vegetable oil rant and we've cleared
this up at nauseum over here at aby's
kitchen but to summarize while some
Studies have pointed to the potential
inflammatory properties of getting too
much omega-6 in the diet the larger body
of high quality evidence suggests that
Omega 6 fats do not have a significant
effect on inflammation in fact a 2012
systematic review assessed the effects
of omega-6 linolic acids on inflammatory
markers and found no strong link to
suggest that they increased inflammation
as for the Bobby approved formula
recommendations this one is a toddler
formula which is used when most infants
can actually literally come off formula
so unhelpful suggestion and both the LCA
and the hip contain vegetable oil as a
third ingredient which was one of the
main things he just ripped into so these
may have other unique features that make
them the right choice for some families
but they're significantly more expensive
and way less accessible than drugstore
Brands the last thing that parents need
is to be mansplained misinformation when
they are literally just trying to do the
best damn job that they can I am trying
really hard to keep it kind here because
watching Bobby's content makes me ragy
AF you wouldn't like me when I'm
angry but let's move on to this gut
health tip from Liz cyber they say that
the gut is like the second brain once I
learned how to eat in a way that was gut
healing my mental health completely
transformed today I'm going to show you
how to make one of my favorite easy gut
healing breakfast and it's going to keep
you full for hours starting with a lot
of high quality butter that I get from a
farm we're going to add carrots onions
broccoli a clove of garlic then we're
just going to stir fry this in the
butter the reason that we're using these
vegetables is because they're very low
carb and they're not starchy starch is
one of the things that can really
irritate the gut okay I'm going to stop
the video right here because basically
the rest is just some scrambled eggs
with lots of butter avocado and veg and
it does look delicious but I Flav this
video because of the clear and misguided
message that carbs and starch irritate
the gut now IBS symptoms are very tricky
obvious viously everyone's experience of
what triggers a flare will be unique but
generally speaking we know that starchy
foods are actually hugely beneficial to
the gut if we look at a type of starch
in foods like unripe bananas potatoes
oats rice plantains and legumes called
resistant starch we see that these
actually act as unique Prebiotic fibers
to improve gut health microbiome
diversity short chain fatty acid
production and immune response the
reason why people like Liz who have
taken on a super strict carnivore style
diet may see a reduction in GI symptoms
is that they end up cutting out a ton of
potentially triggering foods but
elimination diets like the controversial
gaps diet that she references in this
video or other bogus gut healing diets
that we hear about online are not meant
to be followed long term you're supposed
to eliminate then reintroduce most of
these foods that you cut out in a
stepwise manner so as Not to cause
long-term harm to microbiome and
unfortunately this is a cycle that we
see in a lot of folks with histories of
disordered eating and eating disorders
which Liz has been very open about
struggling with in the past so I talked
about this in more detail in my video
right here but often Enos orders can
cause functional gut disorders food
sensitivities and motility issues which
then can lead people towards hyper
restrictive diets to try to get some
digestive relief which in the end can
actually do more long long-term damage
in fact in the case of the carnivore
diet one review of the literature found
that people whose diet was low in fiber
and high in animal protein had
microbiome disbiosis and a specific
bacterial ratio in the gut that is
associated with IBD so while the
carnivore diet with low amounts of
beneficial starch or Fiber May
temporarily suppress some GI symptoms It
ultimately is not good for the gut and
speaking of carnivores we have got to
talk talk about this Gem of
misinformation from the carnivore MD
Paul saladino I have elevated
cholesterol but I don't need a stab
here's why in many people like myself we
eat a significant amount of saturated
fat from animal meat and avoid seed oils
LDL cholesterol Rises if I went to a
classically trained doctor they would
beg me to take a stattin but my elevated
cholesterol does not mean that I am at
an increased risk of cardiovascular
disease so much dangerous misinformation
in one short clip so for one anytime I
see an influencer pill shame or
discourage the public from taking a life
saving medication or seeking the advice
of classically trained doctors my eyes
get a little Twitchy look at my eye
twitching I also find it super
convenient that Paul never shares
references or receipts for the studies
he references so I guess I'm going to be
picking up the slack we have and Le
research that high LDL cholesterol can
increase the risk of heart disease
because that cholesterol can bury itself
in the arterial walls cause inflammation
and increase your risk of a heart attack
or stroke now I assume his argument is
based on the heavily criticized review
that concluded that 92% of seniors with
high cholesterol ended up living longer
suggesting that the benefits of a Statin
treatment had been exaggerated But Not
only was the study criticized for bias
and poor methods but 2third of its
participant pool came from just one
study and even that study found that
Statin use provided a survival benefit
also being metabolically healthy AKA
maintaining low insulin levels doesn't
erase the damage that LDL can do to
one's arteries nor does it mean that he
wouldn't benefit from a Statin one
20year study of men with no heart
disease risk factors other than high LDL
cholesterol and no evidence of heart
disease found that just 40 Mig of a weak
Statin reduced coronary deaths by
28% honestly I don't really give a what
Paul does but I do care what kind of BS
he is spewing to the
masses bullsh and finally let's finish
off with Coach Jeremy who apparently had
his Halloween doctor costume do double
duty this year with this notoriously
misinformed video yo are you serious
right now do you realize that doctors
are literally poisoning young children
in this country when you turn back and
you see the label not only does it have
sucrose which is an artificial sweetener
that disturbs the brain but we have red
40 which has been proven to cause
hyperactivity in the brain and then
guess what that same doctor wants to
prescribe your young child with a
methamphetamine like adero whoa whoa
whoa that escalated from like red 40 is
dangerous to fullblown conspiracy theory
that doctors are giving their patients
ADHD to make money off of prescriptions
honestly this makes me sick I don't know
if this guy has ever met a child who has
been sick but if your kid is a very high
fever and is like puking having diarrhea
and not wanting to eat or drink anything
you are head to the ER you don't give a
about a little suc Lo or red 40 you want
your child to get better and rehydrate
because dehydration is a major cause of
morbidity and mortality in infants and
young children children worldwide
largely from acute viruses that cause
diarrhea but to just set the record
straight on a few things sucrose AKA
Splenda is considered safe in moderate
amounts with human research showing no
negative impact on gut health and while
I wouldn't personally recommend children
consume artificial sweeteners like
sucrose daily a little bit of sweetener
to encourage kids to drink an
electrolyte supplement that could very
well save a life is absolutely not a
concern as for food d red 40 was
actually phased in as like a safer
alternative to red 3 because red 3 was
linked to thyroid cancer in rats as for
hyperactivity a 2004 analysis of 15
studies did find that artificial food
dyes like red 40 did slightly increase
hyperactivity in children while other
research suggests that this effect is
genetically determined and not all
children react the same another meta
analysis found an association though not
necessarily A causal
between food dyes and autism so even
though this is all quite inconclusive
and correlation is not causation I do
think that there's reason to be cautious
with overc consumption that said if your
kid is exhausted from dehydration the
benefits of a rehydration solution far
at weigh any potential small boost in
hyperactivity and if your child is
sensitive there are unsweetened and die
free options as a mom I'll be honest I
do try to avoid food dyes under normal
everyday circumstances but I can't
really imagine my kids wanting to drink
salty clear liquid when they don't want
to eat or drink anything at all so I
will take a life-saving sweetened dyed
substance on occasion over my kidne to
go to the ER to be put on a drip but you
know what we are lucky to have options
here and when Jeremy has kids and his
kids are violently ill he can do that
risk benefit analysis for himself well
folks there's no shortage of crazy
unhinged Wellness advice making its
rounds and you know I will always be
here taking it down as it comes our way
so don't forget to hit that subscribe
button for more diet culture BS take
down content like this video check out
my description for my free Hunger
crushing combo ebook and I'll see you
next time on aby's kitchen
[Music]
cheers